[Music]
first of all thank you so much for
coming in today sir I really appreciate
it rajen um I I want to jump right on in
but the only reason Collider gets to be
at the Toronto Film Festival is because
of our sponsors it's expensive to cover
these things I want to give a huge thank
you to Nordstrom Canada for being a
great sponsor and allowing us to cover
this amazing festival and Thank You
Nordstrom Canada I really appreciate it
mr. Deakins I just want to start by
saying congratulations on winning for
Blade Runner 2049 some small award that
they give out to very talented
cinematographers I'm gonna start with
that thank you it was I were you aware
of everyone so many people like rooting
for you to win I guess I was yes
probably yes okay no I'm just saying I
thought your work on that film was
absolutely brilliant and one of the
things I want to get into Goldfinch but
one of the things that really I took
away from your lighting in your films is
always so realistic and one of the
things that I thought about Blade Runner
was that it allowed you to use more
impressionistic lighting or more
artistic lighting experimental if you
will in this in some of the scenes was
that like something really exciting for
you on that project yeah I was actually
it's a big a big thing about that
project for me yeah it gave me sort of
the latitude to sort of play with
lighting and do some setups that I had
only done in small situations previously
yeah it's just a much larger canvas yeah
you don't often get that sort of
opportunity on a film because it well
especially I don't because the kind of
films I like to do a much more
character-driven than they are big showy
kind of action movies or anything like
that so this film other that's not a big
action film it had large sets and it had
a scope that I more than probably
anything I've done for a long long time
right one of the things was some of the
shots are so breathtaking like I was I
could pause them on blu-ray
and just examine the canvas and just be
so amazed at the different lighting
setups and the the colors how much if
you don't mind me asking how much of
that was all pre-planned and in previz
or just you storyboarding and how much
are those things found in the moment
each day we story voted it quite a bit I
mean Denny and I storyboarded the film
over a couple of months I was in
Montreal staying in a hotel every he was
cutting his previous film and every
afternoon he'd come around and we just
do storyboards but I mean in front of
the lighting that was something I made
up in pre-production discussion with the
designer and know everything was very
well very detailed Lee planned out
because it had to be because a lot of
the sets you only see on for like short
scenes oh for one scene and maybe a come
you know six minute scene but it's only
a single scene but it required a certain
kind of lighting and that had to be
pre-planned and pre-rigged like weeks in
advance of the day of the shoot so I
mean all the way through the shoot I was
working at weekends and looking at the
lighting and getting everything prepared
for the you know the week's actual
shooting if you if you don't mind me
with I'm gonna indulge me in one more
question when you think back on making
that film was there a shot or two that
you still can't believe you were able to
pull off no I don't you know don't
really think like that I think every
just like that really no I mean a film
is something that you don't want any
shot to be kind of outside of all the
others in a way you know you want
everything to sort of feel as a piece I
don't like it and obviously people do
they say oh that's shot how did you like
that or something you know what in a way
that's my failure because you shouldn't
really nothing should specifically stand
out you're trying to put the audience in
a world that they're immersed in and
everything should flow as a piece you
know you know sound what I mean
completely but how do you feel though
because what's interesting about I love
a long Runner where you know I think
about Goodfellas and I think
that longshot through the dining room or
I think about atonement and so I guess
what I'm saying is do you think that
those kind of shots sort of add a sort
of sense of suspense or something or do
you know what I mean
well it did but you have to judge when
you use a long single shot or where you
cut I mean
Blade Runner wood was in general a much
more sort of cerebral piece of work you
know if I like if I liken it to anything
that was much more like you know
Tarkovsky Solaris in a sense that you
know you don't want to have big or stent
ostentatious camera moves and stuff it's
it's much more what's happening within
the frame it's a more subtle thing than
that really I think anyway but whether
that comes out in the result I don't
know that that's where I kind of come
from in a way sure I think there's times
to move the camera there's times to
follow a character and there's times to
stay back and allow that character to
observe that the audience to observe
that character within the space you know
what I mean I mean it doesn't always
want to be wandering around with a
Steadicam you know sometimes it's
actually a distraction sometimes it
would be stronger just see keep this
camera static on a wide shot you know
sometimes if we bet the actors sat down
and you just looked at his face instead
of he's wandering around all these
wonderful locations that's the balance
you know that's just that that's the
trick how often have you composed a shot
through your career and had it like us
you have an actor sitting on the couch
you have everything set up you filmed a
take or two and you realize okay this is
just not working at all we need to reach
ange this completely not reach Ange it
completely been quite often a director
and I we've kind of looked at in going
you know we're missing a trick here we
don't need to do that we can come over
here and just play it static over here
and let the person do that we don't need
to see them or you know I yeah I've only
ever once gone to directing this was
with Joel and Ethan on hudsucker proxy
and it was like I was struggling to like
this set
and I went to them about 11 o'clock in
the morning and said I'm sorry I've got
to change it's all completely I want to
start again and I said well okay we'll
break for lunch early and and that's
what we did and then an afternoon it was
fine that's the only time I've ever
changed something completely because I
didn't like it I usually I do a lot of
preparation and and and usually you go
to a plan but shots yes you can change
shirts a lot one of the things that I
found fascinating learning about you and
I think I mentioned talk to you about
this
maybe with prisoners or previously is
that you often well I guess most of the
time you you you don't do a lot of
coverage you have one camera on set and
you you shoot it and that's it so I
guess my question is when was the last
time you did extensive coverage on a
movie do you I guess let me start with
that don't think I ever have really I
mean maybe a film I didn't enjoy being
on air America no I haven't really been
on a film I've done extensive coverage
air America was the only film I've been
on where I've done a dialogue scene with
more than two or three cameras usually I
just do a shoot everything with one
camera and operate myself yeah you can
only put one shot on a screen at a time
unless you're doing something fancy
I don't I just can't get my head around
shooting something multiple cameras it
seems such a compromise like with
Goldfinch let's jump into that real
quick yeah should do right no I was
getting there but with Goldfinch you
have for example certain scenes where
you have you know you have two actors
two people talking and you have one shot
on this actor one shot on this actor and
it's cutting back and forth
how are you typically shooting something
like that are you so you're shooting you
know can you describe how you would
shoot something like just treated won't
coverage one way first and then during
the reverse second so it's so Jones
actually concentrated concentrating on
the performance of a particular actor
it's intense conversation I mean I have
an occasion like for instance on dead
man walking we were doing some very
intense scenes with Sean and
in jail cell Oh between the bars and it
was like a lot of it where they were
doing was intense and ad-libbing
and then I did use two cameras to shoot
the cat you know shoot two overs because
it would be really almost impossible to
match that kind of performance from one
to another but usually it's a director's
preference to have a single camera and
concentrate on a single performance got
you obviously I'm sure you get asked by
many filmmakers to do many projects what
was it about Goldfinch that said I want
to do this project
oh I mean it does the whole story the
book I mean the films the projects I'd
like to be involved on a sort of
character driven pieces and this was you
know to the nth degree a character
driven pace you know and and yeah so
that's what drew me to it there's not
that many of them sadly well they're
harder and harder yeah yeah it's I have
you have you what I was gonna say it
seems like at the theaters nowadays it's
more and more escapist fare you know
it's definitely yeah so one of the
things one of the powerful sequences in
the film is the the bombing sequence in
the museum and the way it's building and
the way it's flashed back to could you
talk about filming that sequence and you
know how you and John discuss the way it
was gonna look
ya know and that was obviously key to
the whole story it's is the one event in
the in Theo's life that leads to
everything else in his life
yeah we discussed that a lot I mean and
John was very keen that the aftermath
was kind of like a void you know which
is kind of a difficult thing to do
technically if you don't don't have a
huge space and obviously the set we had
matched the actual real location so the
size of the gallery was of a specific
size so then to make the aftermath feel
like it was like a huge beyond you know
that this little kid is standing up in
the middle of nowhere and then that was
the challenge but that's that was what
we were trying to get to in terms of the
flashbacks to it we didn't want it to be
a big kind of action II sort of feel
to the scene we didn't want to be you
know a big explosion see the building
all this we wanted it now what I mean
what do you remember of anything that's
traumatic them in your life I mean I
know I remember details I remember
little things and that's what we sort of
concentrated on the idea of Theo's
memory is this the mother walking away
out of focus or her hand leaving his
shoulder or the musical instrument case
case just disappearing out of peppers
hands you know as those little things
that I think I think that's what truth
is that's what sticks in your mind
somehow jerk move don't you typically do
you ever when you're filming obviously
Goldfinch how do you look at do you ever
make requests of the director in terms
of when you want to schedule something
to be shot in the production like do you
find that you know like the bombing
sequence you want to get to it midway
through the shoot or you want to get to
it right at the beginning not not so
often in terms of the overall share draw
I do that a lot in terms of when I want
to shoot what time of day I want to
shoot a scene or something like that or
then we talk about logistics in a
schedule because you know you can't oh
it's very hard to put a lot of difficult
sets and complicated lighting passing up
against each other so you want to kind
of have some pre light time you know
that kind of stuff but in terms of
whether you put a scene like that
upfront or no it dictated itself in a
way in our schedule when we did the
museum because we had we had to do the
actual last scene of the film which is
Theo and his mother in the museum
looking at the paintings before we did
the explosion because that's the way we
had a set and then we had to destroy it
so you know it had it had its own built
in schedule for it in a way you know I
sure had we're only New York for a
certain time then we went to Amsterdam
and then we went to Albuquerque so you
know you can't you can't go to
Albuquerque and then come back to it New
York well you can this was not a very
you know wasn't a big-budget movie
because it was yeah I understand
completely
one of the thing I'm just did you know
did John tell you what he was thinking
about what the editing process of what
he was gonna have the film final film
look like with the Edit in terms of
going back and forth and you know and
how did that possibly impact the look of
any parts of the film well he did but in
not so much specifically because he was
saying I mean we know the the whole
thing being a bookend that was in the
script but he knew he wanted more of the
aftermath of the explosion because he
knew he wanted to go back and forth with
those elements during the film but he
had our ideas where that would go but it
wasn't that specific and that was
something he knew it get into the
cutting room and he wanted the options
there sure
you obviously have two different time
periods in the film how did you and John
talk about the look of each of the time
periods and if you wanted them to be
similar to be a little different if you
could talk about that no the time period
not so much photographically I mean not
in terms of anything you're doing with a
camera the lens I mean what was
important to get the difference between
the locations so you're you you know you
Amsterdam wanted its own particular look
as opposed to New York and then
obviously Las Vegas which we did in
Albuquerque that wanted a totally
different look again you know they're
kind of that hostile light of that
nature you know what kind of cameras did
you use on Goldfinch and has it been the
the same camera you've been using for a
while yeah I mean I've been only using
the Alexa digital camera which I've been
using now since in time yeah I've done
one film on film since then which was
hell Cesar but yeah it's this same
camera I was using on Skyfall for
instance and Blade Runner do you have
your own set of lenses at this point are
you renting based on the film no
actually I I've used the same set of
lenses well not actually these sames
that are lenses the same make of lenses
now for since they came out which I
guess there's a few yet four or five
years ago I tend to use the same
equipment and
I do when new a new set of lenses is
developed I'm often involved in testing
them before they come out and if there's
something I think are better than the
last ones then I start using those and
went wait for an excellent I'm not
somebody that goes oh well this film I'm
gonna use this sort of lens and this
film I'm gonna use that sort of you know
I don't I don't swap between different
kind of old lenses with a coating go on
and all that stuff I'm I'm not there
actually are you looking forward to
seeing this I wasn't gonna ask this but
are you are you looking forward to
seeing the lighthouse because they yeah
because I saw it the other day and it's
it visually is unlike anything that's
been made well I thought which was as
well I thought that was the
extraordinary piece of work yeah that
was really stunning I mean I don't often
gravitate towards that kind of horror
film but that was so well done which so
I I'm really looking forward to like
house yeah way he uses very old cameras
and old lenses and it achieves a very
very unique yeah yeah yeah oh there's
certain time there are a certain time
but I just didn't go Goldfinch one I
mean when we did Jesse James I took
these lens and manufactured lenses
specifically for that film so I'm not
against using different kind of you know
a different technique technical
techniques and a different kind of
lenses and manipulating the image i
manipulated the image no brother we're
out there but it depends on the film I'm
not going to do that I sound like
Goldfinch which actually you want to
immerse it's a it's a character film and
you want to immerse the audience in the
characters and you don't want them to be
aware of the surface you're not trying
to tell them now we're in a period film
this is an old film or this is gonna be
you know what I mean it's like
completely yeah listen I love Jesse
James that film is brilliant what will
it take to get that film released on
criterion I don't know it should be I
would really like to see the long
version the first cut that I saw
released on criteria and that's what I'd
hoped for can I ask how long that one
was it was over three hours but I mean I
don't think ever will because Andrew
last time I talked to him issues
go now about it he he was quite happy
with a version that got released but I
still remember that first the early cut
that I saw that was like three and a
quarter I think and I thought it was no
it may be as long as matte but it's
pretty stunning I was a 4-hour version
the first cut was like four hours I've
seen I have to tell you I think that he
captured something you together you guys
captured something amazing and I would
pay good money to see any longer version
yeah well I think I agree I mean I think
what he got was the book if you ever
read the book a Handsome's book it has
that sort of mythical kind of poetic
feeling about it the feel you know a
kind of pecking power feeling of
something passing you know the world
changing and these characters being kind
of left behind by the world I'm feeling
myself right now no I refuse to accept
that and but no I think I think he's a
he's a very gifted filmmaker and that
that film just as magic on it it's just
a great piece of work but I have to ask
are you a little bummed you couldn't
shoot dune well course of course but
then on the other hand I can't say that
because I'm so so proud and happy to
shoot with Sam Mendes again yeah I mean
you know what can you do I moved I was
actually I was so pleased he asked me
because I didn't do the bond with him
the last Bond film with him and I was
very pleased he asked me back to do 1917
because if there was ever a film that I
felt had my name on it was that film
I am I I don't want to ask you about the
film because I know they're being
guarded with everything but I can ask
that one said anything right exec no I'm
just gonna be I'll just ask you where
are you did you guys wrap where are you
in the postpone oh yeah we wrap we wrap
yeah no we wrapped gonna be timing it
early October I think mid October
something like that I know it has a
December release date Christmas diable
yeah I was gonna say when do you think
you guys will have a finished version of
that Phil
that people can actually see no I don't
know you'll have to ask is it going to
be cutting it close
I don't know I don't think so no I don't
see why would I mean no I think it's all
gonna be gonna be on schedule and fine
but I just don't know when they're
planning to start showing it you've done
bond you've done Blade Runner you've
worked in you've worked with so many
different things is there a current
franchise or filmmaker out there that
you're like that you would love to work
on or work with or does it sort of not
work like that with you there is but it
doesn't work like that anyway does it I
mean you know yeah you know so many
filmers have have the crews they work
with and that's the way it is you know
sure times you get lucky yeah good what
is it gonna take for me to get you and
Chris McQuarrie together to make Mission
Impossible or to film the Mission
Impossible I'm sorry I don't never
happened I don't I don't like those
movies it's a terrible thing to say
isn't it I love Chris McQuarrie but sure
I appreciate people that actually say
the truth and don't try to sugarcoat
like oh I love it but do you know what I
mean
no I mean sorry no no it's fine um do
you know what you were gonna do next
after no so if anybody's got a project
I'm really looking for something right I
for some reason I don't think it'll be
hard for you to get a job I don't know
it's please like I appreciate the
humbleness but my god I'm sure that
there's about ten filmmakers that would
scream you know well put this out that
cuz I don't know right now okay I'll
leave it there my last thing for you I
love what do you think you're working
with the Alexa camera I love when
technology is able to help the creative
process what do you think there is
coming in with technology that maybe
we'll be able to accomplish something
you haven't been able to accomplish if
anything well I think I think the big
development now is is because the size
of the cameras are becoming smaller and
smaller the big development is gimble's
and how you can move the
I mean I think that's gonna have a huge
effect he already is having a huge
effect on films but it'll be rather like
when Steadicam first came out everybody
saw but the camera under steady camera
will sort of wander around and call it
filmmaking it's it's not it's another
tool and it's been overused and I'll say
the same thing will happen with gimbals
and small cameras you know once once we
you know Hollywood start shooting films
like you know guys going around with
their little you know Home Videos sure
which is what we'll be doing then that
style will be rampant but it will be so
boring and then somebody will do
something like Andrei Tarkovsky and put
the camera there and go like that and
they'll go oh my god all like there's
something like our breasts on movie and
they'll go by god that's revolutionary
my last thing for you because I know I
got to go what do you think but right
now I've seen a lot of shots not in
major films but I've seen a lot of shots
on YouTube and other places where people
are using drones to achieve shots that
have never been done in cinema history
or in movies how do you feel about like
drones and you foresee them being used
by yourself or other filmmakers in films
yeah I mean I've used drones but you got
to ask yourself why that's the thing is
the same as Steadicam okay it's a tool
but why it's not just because you use it
because you got it you don't use it
you've got to say why do I want to use
it is that really the way I want to
communicate that part of the story sure
um listen I could talk to you for
another three hours but I know you have
to go do other interviews again I really
sincerely say thank you so much your
work and Goldfinch as all your other
work is fantastic thank you thank you so
much to Nordstrom Canada for letting us
be a Toronto the Toronto Film Festival
thank you so much sir